منطقه المواصي اقصى غرب خانيونس مثلها مثل
باقي مناطق المحافظه فهي في مرمى جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي برغم ادعته بانها
منطقه امنه عشرات المصابين والشهداء وقعوا
في هذه المنطقه منذ بدء العمليه العسكريه
الموسعه غرب خان يونس انا وانا مارق
طريق تعرضت كاره وجنبها شب ل قذيفه استشهد
الشب وانا تعرضت
لاصابه وويت في
بيت وقويت في بيت ساعه زمن لبل تروح
الطيران و وحاولت اشرط اشرط اشرط لما وصلت
المنطقه ناس وصلوني الهين ومع ارتفاع حده
العدوان الاسرائيلي وحتميه وقوع الاصابات
اقيمت هنا نقاط اسعاف تقدم خدمات اسعافيه
سريعه للمصابين ثم تنقلهم لمشافي في رفح
بسبب حصار الاحتلال لعدد من المشافي منذ
خروجنا من مستشفى ناصر
قهرا وحده الاسعاف والطوارئ في مستشفى
ناصر عملت هنا نقطه طبيه على منطقه النص
منطقه شارع رشيد كي تلبي النداء
لمصابين استقبلنا منذ 15 يوم حتى الان
اكثر يزيد عن 300 اصابه واكثر من 20 شهيد
تلقت هذه النقطه الطبيه هي نقطه اسعاف
وليس نقطه طبيه نقطه اسعاف هنا يواجهون
صعوبات في العيش ومخاطر الموت مش اول مره
هذا وكانه المصي مستهدفه وكانهم طالبوا
الناس بالنزوح طالبوا وين يروحوا الناس
يعني رفع بقول لك مستهدفه الان مثلا جيش
الاحتلال وقاده الاحتلال بقول المرحله
المقبله رفع طب وين بدهم الناس يروحوا وين
نروح يعني ما في مكان امن في هذه المنطقه
ارتقت صباح اليوم الفتاه سميره شراب مسكت
الفطيره وبدها تضر وقفت هنا على الثلاجه
الرصاص
هنا نا عتله وكلنا ماترش ول تسافر دام
والله ما افطرت دبكت تاكل فيها راحت هي
الدم حتشوف هي الدم يؤثرون البقاء هنا تحت
زخات الرصاص والقصف المستمر على نزوح
محفوف بالمخاطر يقول اهالي القطاع فقد
الامن في
غزه اسماعيل ابو عمر قناه الجزيره خان
يونس